das ist wirklich ihre der friedhof der
raumschiffe point nemo
es ist der wohl abgelegenste ort der
erde überhaupt teilnehmen und zwischen
chile und neuseeland und mehr als 2000
kilometer vom nächsten stückchen land
entfernt und genau dort ist auch der
friedhof der raumschiffe wie es dort
aussieht und wie die sterbenden
raumschiffe genau beerdigt werden jetzt
in klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
weltraumschrott ist nicht nur müll
sondern tatsächlich ein unkalkulierbares
risiko erst vor kurzem haben wir hier
darüber berichtet dass teile der
chinesischen raumstation tiangong 1
schon bald auf die erde stürzen werden
denn die chinesen haben die kontrolle
über die station verloren und gehen
jetzt davon aus dass tiangong 1 ende des
jahres spätestens im frühjahr 2018
abstürzen wird ein großteil wird wurde
in der atmosphäre verbrennen
doch experten experten warnen davor dass
grosse trümmerteile von bis zu 100
kilogramm auf die erde treffen werden
aber auch die unzähligen anderen
trümmerteile die den weltraum
mittlerweile regelrecht vermüllen
stellen eine bedrohung für uns da das
sagen forschungsteams weltweit die nasa
warnt vor einer unkontrollierbaren
kettenreaktion eine absolute katastrophe
dass kessler syndrom ausgelöst durch
einen crash werden innerhalb von stunden
großteile der flugkörper rund um die
erde zerstören inklusive der
internationalen raumstation iss immer
wieder schlittern wir daran vorbei es
gab bereits 200 kollisionen im orbit der
erde und jede produziert wieder neue
schrott teilchen zwischen geht man von
166 millionen trümmerteilen aus die um
die erde schwören wir sind im moment
quasi zeuge eines kessler syndroms in
zeitlupe spektakulärer höhepunkt 2009
stoßen der us-satellit nummer 33 des
iridium satellitentelefon netzes gewicht
eine halbe tonne und der russische
satellit cosmos 2251 zusammen bei einer
aufprallgeschwindigkeit von 40.000
kilometern bleibt von beiden satelliten
nichts mehr übrig außer rund 100000
schrott teilchen sie haben jetzt die
chancen für den nächsten unfall deutlich
erhöht damit das risiko für eine solche
katastrophe sinkt werden ausgediente
raumschiffe satelliten und sonstige welt
raumflugkörper beerdigt und zwar hier
auf der erde
dafür haben sich die weltweiten
weltraumagenturen den isolierten punkt
der welt ausgesucht point nemo eine
stelle im südlichen pazifik rund 2600
kilometer vom hexen stück land entfernt
konkret von dead island einem teil der
pid kern insel
motor einer neben insel der osterinseln
und maria island was zur antarktis
gehört und das ist wirklich ein riesiger
abstand wenn er euch vorstellt dass die
raumstation iss in rund 400 kilometern
höhe um die erde kreist deswegen ist
point nemo übrigens auch als pazifischer
pohl der unzulänglichkeit bekannt etwa
zwei wochen braucht man um dorthin mit
dem schiff zu kommen und natürlich auch
wieder zwei wochen um zurück zu gelangen
das risiko dass ein trümmerteil auf land
einschlägt dass gezielt support nemo
gesteuert wurde
ist also nahezu null die gefahr dass
hier irgendjemand geschädigt wird ist
absolut minimal obwohl ich könnte mir
einen katastrophenfilm vorstellen bei
dem zum beispiel ein atomgetriebenes
schiff von einer raumstation getroffen
wird ja aber das ist dann doch doch
wirklich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu
viel fiction imo wurde übrigens mit
hilfe eines computerprogramms entdeckt
und zwar im jahr 1992 von dem
kroatischen vermessungstechniker luca
täler den namen hat dieser ort
allerdings nicht von dem fisch nemo aus
dem zeichentrickfilm sondern eine
romanfigur und zwar kino aus 20.000
meilen unter dem meer von jules verne an
dieser stelle im ozean vermutet man nur
sehr wenig leben denn der wind kann nur
wenig nährstoffe hin tragen da das
nächste stück land so weit entfernt
liegt starke meeresströmung halten
nährstoffreiches wasser zudem ab also
wirklich der ideale ort um alles zu
begraben was man nicht mehr braucht laut
nasa ist dies vor allem für größere
objekte wie raumstationen und raum
fahrzeuge die sich in einer niedrigen
umlaufbahn befinden eine hervorragende
möglichkeit denn bei ihnen besteht die
gefahr dass sie eben nicht vollständig
verbrennen bevor sie den erdboden
erreichen solche raumschiff und
satelliten werden dann ganz kontrolliert
zum point nemo gebracht und dort dann
zum absturz es gibt schätzungen nach
denen hier sagt weshalb 71 mehr als 260
raumfahrzeuge beerdigt worden sind und
die zahl ist in den letzten jahren
gewaltig gestiegen
unter anderem ist hier auch die mir die
122 tonnen schwere russische
raumstationen begraben russische objekte
sind übrigens deutlich in der überzahl
wohl mehr als 200 objekte aus russland
sind dabei und der friedhof ist alles
andere als klein unvorstellbare
17 millionen quadratkilometer soll der
groß sein und auch die iss wird wohl
demnächst an diesem ort für immer ihre
letzte ruhestätte finden am point nemo
schlummern also große teile der
weltraumgeschichte am meeresboden eine
wirklich beeindruckende vorstellung in
das ding vielleicht können wir diesen
raumschiff friedhof ja mal besichtigen
ja viele fragen ja immer mal wieder nach
unserem equipment die links dazu habe
ich in die video beschreibung gepackt
wenn er noch fragen habt stellt sie mir
in den kommentaren wenn ihr kein video
zum thema weltraumschrott und auch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergessen nicht den achtung genau
auf die glocke denn nur dann verpasst er
kein video wie zum beispiel dieses hier
weltraumschrott das ende der raumfahrt
droht mit noch mehr infos zum drohnen
keppler syndrom absolut spannendes thema
und ansonsten wie immer bis dann bleibt
dran